- Recherche mise sur pause,
ressources détournées,
la pandémie de COVID-19 a fait
mal à la recherche sur le VIH
ainsi qu'à la préventiontititit.
Conséquence : l'ONU rapporte
1,5 million de nouveaux cas
de VIH pour 2021
plus d'un million de plus
que les objectifs mondiaux.
Dr NICOLAS CHOMONT, cherche e eM
- On a perdu probablement
5 5 à 10 ans en termes
de prévention de nouvelles
infections juste à causeC'C'C'Cu
traitement qui estn n problème
et c'est aussi le moins
de dépistage et, quand
on dépe e e e e e e e e e e e es
d'Asie du Pacifique, région
la plus peuplée de la
où la recrudescence du VIH
est la plus importante dans
le monde. Et depuis plusieurs
années, les pays d'Europe
deoyoyoyoyoyoyoyoyoyoyoyoyoyoyoe
du Nord ainsi que de l'Amérique
latine connaissent aussi
À l'inverse, les nouvelles
infections sont en baisse en
Afrique occidentale et centralïe
jeunes séropositifs en Ouganda.
Durant le confinement,
l'absence de soutien en personne
a poussé de nombreux patients à
"Cela a un impact sur
l'efficacité du traitement,
même une fois qu'ils reprennent
la médication", explique-t-elle.
La recherche sur le vaccin
contre la COVID- a a tout
de même eu un effet bénéfique
sur la recherche sur le VIH.
Dr JEAN-PIERRE ROUTY,
- Il y a déjà des études
en cours qui utilisent
la technologies de l'ARN
messager. La compagnie Moderna
des sujets bien portants avec
ceacaccin en mettant du VIH
et pas du COVID, et
on est en train de mesurer
leur réponse immunitaire.
- La guérison d'au moinsi i i i.
Ces personnes, qui ont reçu
une transplantation de moelle
osseuse pour
ont du même coup guéri du VIH.
Les cellules transplantées
comportaient une mutation
les rendant résistantes au VIH.
Dr ÉRIC COHEN,nsnstitut de
recherches cliniques de Montréal
- Il y a des moyens actuellement
génétiqu
d'essayer de mimer ce qui
est fait sur ces patients
par des approches qui
sont moins dange
- Le nerf de la guerre :
le fanancement de la recherche,
financement qui est 4 à 5 fois
moins élevé per capitas,s,s,s,s,
selon les organisateurs
de la conférence.
Ionononononononononononononono.